and that you lost some a role in the new
Superman movie no no no no no nothing to
do with that the Hollywood just decided
to change the script and I'm sure
Hollywood is not controlled by the Zion
Oh no no no no
no one um is a charity organization that
operates on a 100% donation policy they
do great works like providing clean
water food Aid shelter responding to
natural disasters and they do this in
many countries around the world you can
share in the rewards of everything they
do and offer to the umah by subscribing
to the ongoing sodaka fund this charity
has been around for over 10 years and
I've personally known them for over 10
years I've personally worked with them
for over 10 years and they're not paying
me to do this W but this is a charity
that I trust and I trust in Allah
subhana wa tala and I want you the
benefit and get the most out of your
charity so click on the link below and
act
now so brothers and sisters as you know
Basu who is somebody who has absolutely
annihilated and shown the double SS and
hypocrisy of the western system to PE
Moran the biased dog yes to many many
people alhamdulillah and now apparently
what we know that's come out recently is
that he was supposed to be casting for a
Superman movie but don't be surprised
don't be shocked at all for some odd
reason they canceled him they changed
the script nothing to do with the stuff
that he said nothing to nothing to do
with him being pro Palestinian nothing
to do with him being a human being and
saying you know stop the genocide and
the apde and the massacre of the killing
of men women and children innocent
babies 30 ,000 people no no no no no
nothing to do with that the Hollywood
just decided to change the script and
I'm sure Hollywood is not controlled by
the Zionist oh no no no no no oh
definitely they're not never in top
positions you know zionists you've been
very outspoken in behalf of palis and
humanity and that you lost some a role
in the new Superman movie and some other
projects in the United States of America
you can talk about Joe Biden and you can
talk about Donald Trump but you cannot
criticize uh foreign government which is
kind of like very sad you
know and then because of that I I was I
was Cat in the movie Superman and then
they told me we change the script after
Fe Mor and I want to assume good faith
this is the thing that we need to
dissect when I attack Israel and attack
its policy right I'm not attacking
Jewish people they are not in those top
positions calling the shot they don't
Lobby they don't have lobbies in place
which um helped the influence Senate
members to make decisions Pro Israeli oh
hell no they don't have control in these
areas at all in the parliament oh no no
no here's a video clip of brother Basim
Yu explaining the situation and even
though he's assuming the best uh
thinking saying that oh maybe it's
change script I'm not buying it and I
know neither are you guys here's a clip
guys I'm here to address this Superman
Fiasco once and for all because the
internet twists facts words and
basically everything else first of all
I'm a huge fan of James gun nothing but
love and respect for this guy now here's
what happened last June one day before
the actor strike I get an audition for a
role in the new super from my movie I do
the audition I send it in less than an
hour I got a call from my agent he told
me James going to love the tape and he
wants to have a zoom call with you I
have a great call with James he tells me
he likes to interview his actors so to
make sure that everybody has good
chemistry on set everybody who works in
the business know that this is a great
day you do an audition 1 hour you get
the call it's an amazing thing right me
and my agents we celebrate the The
univers Smiling for us and then months
go by October 7th ago peace Mor show I
do two interviews and then um after the
interview right after this strike ends
we get a call from the studio said B is
no longer with us because the script has
been changed now you see where I can see
that from my point of view the timing
was bad even if it a script change this
looks very bad because a lot of people L
also roles because of their political
stat now this happened in November I
never spoke about it I was sad for 3
days and I put it behind me I didn't
want to make a big deal out of it I went
on the Chris K podcast by the way you
have to watch this episode it's great
and by the way Chris you're a wonderful
person often on camera he's amazing and
I think he can kick my ass on a one1
basketball game and he's jacked anyways
after we were done with the interview he
asked me uh if I lost any opportunities
because of my position and I tell the
story and then as I was telling the
story I felt that there was a little bit
of a residual of of anger and bitterness
in me and and I didn't like that so the
next two days I go on BBC talk with and
you know with salon and they asked me
again did I lose any opportunities and
this time I tell the story but this time
there was no anger there was no
bitterness there was nothing and I tried
to be as empathic as possible and you
can watch the interviews and because the
BBC hard talk we're going to go on live
in a couple of days and it's going to be
the same storm all over again please
watch the interviews I really talked
about it in a very calm way and I just
wanted to I wanted to to look and and
and view it from the other side but as I
said in the interview I I do want to
believe that there was no in intention
and I think it was an honest oversight
and I hope I'm true and I hope there was
nothing else but that right and I
haven't thought about it and I and I
don't like complain or victimize myself
or sulk I'm actually very grateful for
the career that and the life that I have
to travel and to earn by living by
making people laugh is the greatest gift
ever B you can see what kind of
character he has what kind of person he
is for that matter that he is assuming
the best the prophet peace be upon him
said the believer is not bit from the
same place twice so what we say is this
brother and sisters yeah we do not buy
it we do not buy it it is very clear and
categorically that the Western system
not just from the political angle from
all angles of freedom of speech to
everybody except Muslims yeah yes um uh
whatever is for that matter but even
when it comes to the movie industry you
dare you dare to side with Humanity
against people being massacred and
killed oh no no no no no can you imagine
we are living at a time in the 21st
century with our uplifting morality that
when a group of people Muslims and
non-muslims for that matter who are
hitting the streets going to the streets
and protesting and people like Basim Yu
who are calling the double standing and
hypocrisy of the Western World they are
being categorized as what you are
pro yeah okay brothers and sisters as
you can see the double standards and
hypocrisy it's the face mask the mask
has been dropped from all of these
individuals absolute utter Hypocrites
the Ukrainian War to what's going on
there you can see guys I've always said
it and I'll say it again like Muhammad
said you know they are strategically
consistent they are not morally
consistent we as Muslims were blamed for
Isis caran atrocities claiming to use
our scripture ironically now which is
actually we were speaking out against it
ironically now the Zionist dogs scums
from the parliament top to bottom are
all quoting Biblical scripture of am
Malachite and justify what they're doing
not only that they are showing and
enacting in ethics of war that they do
not care about men women or children
they were rabbis these Z rabbis coming
out and saying yep you do not spare men
women children you cannot make this up
we want to thank Israel thank you for
showing the whole world because
statistics show everywhere that the
whole world is re realizing and waking
up to the lies that you've been
propagating and the media channels that
you guys control you Zionist and from
top to bottom you think money's going to
buy it it will never buy it and you will
be exposed and a day will come that the
Muslims the Christians and the Jews will
live in peace in Palestine and the end
will come to the apid state and may
Allah allow us to witness that day and
inshallah US seeing that day before we
die we will die in peace and may Allah
allow that day to come inshallah where
these Zionist
nationalist um atheist will see this
inshallah till next time brother and
sisters may Allah bless you guys
inshallah and I want to salute brother
basam Yu for having good morale for for
having amazing character that he even
says you know what it was a change of
script they did not change the script
what did they do they tried to change
the script but you are in the right
place of History because the script of
History which is written by Allah subh
the of Allah subhana tala it is very
clear and best believe like Allah says
do not ever think that Allah is unaware
or what the evil do evildoers do he only
delays them for a day that their eyes
will stare in horror and that day is
surely going to come we do not need icj
the God's judgment is going to be the
just judgment and we are going to see
that and to the farri dogs you utter
Hypocrites scums you double standards
cowards that's where you guys are till
next
time